it's springtime you're outside more it
is time for sunscreen but stay away from
the chemical sunscreens with ingredients
that can irritate skin cause hormonal
disruption or Worse instead use mineral
sunscreen by Ginger armor which is just
as effective you'll get 15 off with code
Pacman at gingerarmor.com the link is
down below
for those who are sick of hearing about
Donald Trump's campaign for 2024's
Republican nomination today may be a
welcome change for you we are going to
take a deeper dive into the last 48
hours of the Ron DeSantis candidacy for
the 2024 Republican Presidential
nomination now one of the things that
will not please those who are sick of
hearing about Trump is that DeSantis is
widely emulating Trump so far in the
early days of his campaign in a number
of different ways including even some of
the insults that Trump uh became famous
for so Ron DeSantis spoke in Iowa
yesterday and there are a number of
different disturbing and comical
realities first and foremost we talked
yesterday about how Ron DeSantis said he
would very much consider pardoning
Donald Trump if he were to become
president if you're running against
Trump you're not going to win by saying
I'll pardon him because the people who
want Trump will vote vote for Trump and
the people who were disgusted by Trump
aren't going to want to go with the guy
that says I will pardon Trump who you
want to get away from you're not going
to beat Trump by avoiding conflict and
criticism the way that DeSantis has done
to a degree in the pre-campaign stages
of the last few months and you're
certainly not going to defeat Trump
by using the same insults that some
people like in which case they'd vote
for Trump and some people don't like in
which case they're not going to vote for
the guy copying the insults and Ron
DeSantis yesterday during this speech in
Iowa going with the Biden is in the
basement thing which is a trump thing
this was Trump's line throughout the
2020 campaign our
where okay
you're not going to win this way Ron I
mean this is if if there's a couple
different issues here first he needs to
defeat Trump before he gets a shot at
Joe Biden and so I you all know I don't
get into this whole Alpha Beta way of
discussing everything by the standards
of these right Wingers it's not very
Alpha to go after the guy you're not
even running against in order to avoid
conflict with the guy who's actually up
30 points in the polls now we're going
to talk about polling a little bit later
because since his announcement DeSantis
is actually up 15 in the polling now
let's remember
15 and 15 percentage points are two
different things before I get emails
saying David what are you talking about
DeSantis is up 15 in the polls we'll
talk about that later but this seems to
be a bump and not a shift in the
underlying dynamics of this campaign
which are that the majority of the
Republican party is fine with Trump and
those that aren't aren't looking for a
guy with the same insults and the same
hand movements who's unwilling to
actually take Trump on head-on and
instead is going to go after Joe Biden
all right let's look at some more clips
from this uh Speech here is DeSantis
talking about the debt deal and you know
one of the really interesting things
about American politics where there's a
history of state level officials vying
for national office Bill Clinton was the
governor of Arkansas and then ran for
president what Bill Clinton had that
DeSantis very much does not have is that
even though Bill Clinton was this sort
of
Southern State Governor
when his campaign for president launched
and he was talking about foreign policy
and debt and deficit Etc he didn't seem
completely in uh over in over his head
you're going to hear Ron DeSantis talk
about debt and you will see that this
state elected official seems completely
out of his element and completely in
over his head when discussing the topics
that are relevant to the National
political scene
[Applause]
we now see Washington has now cooked up
their latest quote debt deal and I can
tell you this our nation was careening
towards bankruptcy before the debt deal
and it will still be careening towards
bankruptcy after this debt deal this is
green lighting four trillion dollars in
new debt in less than two years it took
us almost 200 years to get to 4 trillion
in debt in the first place now remember
when we're talking about the debt
ceiling and the debt limit and all of
this stuff aside from the fact that most
of these elected officials don't even
have the most basic understanding of
macroeconomics like put that aside for a
second the debt limit relates to paying
obligations that have already been
authorized it is not actually about new
spending when these Republicans show up
and say we're to new spending new
spending new spending all of this
spending has already been agreed upon
and it has been agreed upon by our
elected officials in the House and
Senate you might say well I'm a
Republican and when this stuff was
agreed upon we didn't have the house or
Senator okay but this is the process we
have and this is all spending that has
already been authorized now we're
talking about meeting our existing
obligations it locks in inflated covid
level uh uh era levels of spending and
it keeps 98 of the 87 000 new IRS agents
that Joe Biden instituted
is not going to solve our nation's
fiscal problems so again now we are just
quite literally the to Trump lines these
are now I know you're trying to appeal
to Republicans and some of the stuff
Trump does appeals to Republicans and so
you're gonna have to do some of the same
stuff but at some point how are you
going to that this is Trump's lines
delivered in a really just off-putting
way right I mean we're just it's gonna
be dad and it was bankruptcy and I'll
tell so it's the Trump lines delivered
in a winier voice in Florida we run
budget surpluses we have a 1.2 trillion
dollar GDP in Florida we'd be the 13th
largest economy in the world if we were
our separate country and yet with 1.2
trillion economy our state debt is only
17 billion dollars all right so the
crowd not super engaged as you can see
and DeSantis offering nothing that we
might qualify as inspire firing then he
went completely off the rails in
delusions of grandeur saying he believes
we can bring George Washington back and
this is when I mean listen there is some
narcissism probably required to even
think hey I should run for president
maybe people will vote for me but this
is really too much bureaucracy is so
entrenched that I think we can bring
George Washington back can you and I
don't think he could fix it in one
single four-year term but DeSantis can
do it in two terms that's the great news
Nation we
three major institution in our country
going on ideological Joyrides we have to
be guided by Reality by facts and by our
enduring principles we in the State of
Florida held the line when Freedom hung
in the balance
yeah so there is nothing I am seeing
here that makes me think this is
Electric in a way that it's going to put
Trump out with Republican voters the
biggest argument that DeSantis is making
is Florida good I make America like
Florida I am going to argue next that
that would be a disaster all right the
presidential campaign of Ron DeSantis
who is governor of Florida is predicated
on the idea that Florida is great and
that he will make America like Florida
there are all sorts of Articles and
discussions about this Chauncey De Vega
wrote a piece our friend Chauncey uh in
Salon called Ronda santis wants to quote
make America Florida that's a dire
threat the Trump DeSantis race is a boon
for the mainstream media for the rest of
us it's an mitigated disaster and indeed
it is true if the United States became
like Florida it would be a disaster now
oh oh my goodness hold on wait hold but
David you go to Florida all the time
how can you go and say it would be bad
for the entire country to be like
Florida Florida's so bad why are you
going to Florida
I I go to Florida right with uh the
income I earn from my New York business
and with the security of my New York
health insurance knowing that I and my
family have our New York doctors and New
York infrastructure and access to New
York airports I go to Florida to go to
the beach for a week okay this is not an
endorsement of making the country like
Florida there are places in South
Carolina I've been to that are nice but
that doesn't mean South Carolina needs
to be the model for the United States
and when you look at Florida you see
okay it's 25th out of 50 on Health Care
in terms of quality access and cost it's
not a disaster but it's not a model to
be followed when you look at Health Care
in New York Connecticut Massachusetts
Etc Florida is 20th in infrastructure I
it's not nearly the worst but why would
we say that's the infrastructure model
we want to follow Florida is 33rd in
opportunity
26th on crime these aren't great numbers
they're very mediocre numbers they're
not great and they're not terrible but
it doesn't make a say the whole country
should be doing what Florida is doing
Florida also has something that
artificially makes it better in the
rankings than it otherwise would be
which is it has the benefit of money
earned in other states blue States
people from California and from
Washington and from Illinois and from
New York Connecticut Massachusetts who
say hey I'm going to go to Florida for
the weather or I'm going to retire in
Florida and so Florida is the
beneficiary of productivity and income
and money that comes from other states
if every state were like Florida all of
a sudden you lose that benefit you look
at covid DeSantis was quite Reckless
when it comes to the coveted pandemic
and he didn't Institute any meaningful
Public Health measures he in many cases
flouted them and as a result Florida's
coveted death rate we're talking per
capita now is the 10th highest in the
country DeSantis has been a staunch
opponent of Environmental Protection and
climate action and renewable energy if
you spread that to all 50 states it's a
disaster so the bottom line is that if
DeSantis was able to do to the country
what has happened in Florida it would be
very bad for the environment and it
would be very bad for our move towards
renewable energy the santis has been a
fierce advocate of voter suppression and
gerrymandering many states have made
great strides in those areas if DeSantis
had his way
all of that gets reversed he signed
bills that restrict voting rights
limiting mail-in ballots drop boxes
early voting hours he would try to do
that in every state
a vocal opponent of civil rights human
rights and women's rights he signed
bills that ban trans athletes from
participating in school sports limiting
abortion access preventing local
governments from passing
anti-discrimination ordinances this is
all an unmitigated disaster so Florida
can have nice beaches and restaurants
and primarily the liberal areas of
Florida if we're totally honest although
Pensacola is cool okay I will admit that
the state can still be something that we
would want to avoid the entire country
becoming and that is the only promise
that DeSantis is making it's where woke
goes to die and whatever else by the way
speaking of woke we're going to talk
about what's going on with Chick-fil-A
which relates to Florida in some
significant ways that'll be a little bit
later on in the show if you believe
that making the country like Florida
would be a good thing please contact me
info davidpackman.com with the data
skip the rhetoric skip the insults skip
the ad hominems skip the but David you
went to the beach in Miami give me the
data that tells us why making the
country like Florida would be a good
thing make sure you're subscribed to the
YouTube channel of course at youtube.com
slash the David Pacman show back right
after this short break
it is Springtime it's getting warm we
are all spending more time outside many
sunscreens contain elements that the FDA
has warned about oxybenzone Ava benzone
homo sailate and others these are
absorbed into your bloodstream they can
irritate sensitive skin they can be
hormone disruptors I just stay away from
them and I use mineral sunscreens I do
the same when I put sunscreen on my baby
daughter and our sponsor Ginger armor
makes the world's thinnest 100 mineral
sunscreen it works for all skin types
not just gingers as the name might
suggest it rubs in clear on all skin
tones feels like nothing is on with SPF
50 plus protection Ginger armor also
acts as a plant-based moisturizer with
21 simple gentle ingredients from plants
and minerals it's good for you it's good
for the planet it's more affordable than
other sunscreens with similar quality
ingredients I also love that it's a
small business made in the U.S and they
donate one percent of all sales to the
one percent for the planet charity go to
gingerarmor.com use code Pacman for 15
off the link is down below
the David pakman show is a program that
is very different than for example the
daily wire this came up in our
discussion uh yesterday about the
comments made by Cuban American streamer
Stephen Kenneth Destiny Bonnell II The
Daily wire has all these major
millionaire potentially billionaire
donors but I want to be conservative
certainly millionaire donors who just
say hey take money do what you can grow
as fast as you can we don't have that we
actually depend on people like you who
say hey I'm going to get a membership
for six bucks a month or I'll pay for
the entire year and that'll drop it to
the equivalent of five bucks a month or
I'll use a coupon code like 24 starts
now and then it'll only be three bucks a
month so I do want to encourage you if
you value what we're doing and if you
understand the ways in which the right
is so much better positioned in terms of
the media ecosystem than the left
consider getting a membership at
joinpakman.com you'll also get the
benefit of access to the bonus show
yesterday producer Pat told the story of
uh blacking out from heat stroke on
Sunday at a half marathon waking up in
an ice bath and ultimately being brought
by ambulance to the hospital an insane
story and dozens of you dozens and
dozens of people commenting with similar
experiences shockingly and anyway go a
sad event that is quickly going down is
one of the most popular bonus shows in
history sadly because it was a horrible
thing that happened to Pat the bonus
show is available every day to our
members you can sign up at
joinpakman.com all right listen I don't
believe that at this time Ron DeSantis
has a path to the Republican nomination
until something changes unless something
changes but
the numbers can't be denied this is not
a show where I would ever try to deny
the numbers thank your lucky stars every
day you're not Dave Pacman well listen
but I'm not going to deny the numbers
Alex please
since news of Ron desantis's
presidential announcement broke
desantis's polling is up 15 percent
while Donald Trump's polling is down
five percent now I hate that I have to
do this but I need to just do my
disclaimer about the difference between
percent and percentage points if you go
from 10 to 15 percent you start at 10
percent you go to 15 percent that's an
increase of Five Points but it is an
increase of 50 percent okay you've
gained five and you started at 10. that
is a 50 increase but a five point
increase understanding this mathematical
nuance and looking at average polling we
see that Donald Trump peaked at 56.3 and
is now down since the santis
announcement to 53.2 that's a decline of
close to six percent we'll call it five
percent
similarly DeSantis bottomed at 19.4 just
before his announcement and has now
climbed to 22.4 that's an increase of a
little more than 15 percent now is this
an inflection point which in three
months we will look at and Trump will be
down to 30 and DeSantis will be up to 50
Maybe
or is this a short burst for DeSantis
and a short decline for Trump because
DeSantis has been getting way more media
attention lately than Trump has we just
don't know yet if we want to ask a
question that might inform us about
polling it's it's May 31st but we'll
call it the beginning of June what we
might ask is historically how accurate
are primary polls on June 1st of the
year before the election so for example
like in 2016 what was the polling like
June 1st of 2015. we actually have that
data let's put it up on the screen if we
look at 2016
uh in June of 2015 Jeb Bush was leading
by January of 2016 Trump had taken the
lead and Trump ultimately won so in 2016
the leader on June 1st was not
indicative of the eventual winner in
2012 Mitt Romney was leading June of
2011. new Gingrich was leading by
January 1st But Mitt Romney ended up
being the nominee so in 2012 the June
1st polling was indicative of the
eventual winner but it changed if we
look at the Democratic primaries uh the
Democratic primary of 2008 you see that
while Hillary was leading in June of
2007 and in January of 2008 of course
ultimately it was Barack Obama who won
that nomination
and also similarly in 2008 uh in the
Republican primary
a June of the year before Rudy Giuliani
was winning by June 1st Mike Huckabee
had taken the lead but John McCain
ultimately won that primary and we'll
look at a couple others in 2004 June of
2003 it was Joe Lieberman uh January of
2004 Howard Dean had taken the lead of
course the dean's scream we're going to
Iowa
ultimately tanked his campaign John
Kerry the eventual winner of that
primary and then lastly in the year 2000
it was Al Gore in June Al Gore in
January and Al Gore as the eventual
winner so the answer is
often the leader in June of the year
before does not end up being the nominee
that being said usually the leader in
the year before is not a former
president which Donald Trump happens to
be so we are going to follow it but in
the last 10 days or so a significant
gain for DeSantis of about 15 percent
last Ron DeSantis discussion for today
and then we're going to move on to some
other things
a completely and totally deranged Ron
DeSantis appeared on Fox and Friends and
said that if he is elected president he
will destroy leftism destroy leftism hmm
I think he might actually believe this
which is the scariest part that's right
now the time for Ron DeSantis to run for
president
because everyone knows if I'm the
nominee I will beat Biden and I will
serve two terms and I will be able to
destroy leftism in this country and
leave woke ideology on the Dustbin of
History okay so that's a lot if I'm
President we will end Chicken and
Waffles it's just either you want Savory
or you want sweet but we're not going to
allow these leftists from New York City
to come in and tell us that you're going
to put maple syrup on Fried Chicken it's
just not going to happen and it will be
left for the dust spin of History this
is extraordinarily dangerous what he is
saying and there are about a dozen
different concerns with it
and um I'm going to tell you about some
of them now first of all yesterday I
played a clip for you of Rhonda Santa
sing he'd consider pardoning Donald
Trump and meanwhile he's saying that
he's going to destroy leftism from a
purely tactical standpoint I don't see
how you win a Republican primary you're
losing to Trump by 30 by saying you'll
pardon Trump and only talking about Joe
Biden now I know that we've talked about
this before we talked about it at the
top of the show and I know there is
disagreement in my audience about the
strategy of DeSantis running against
Biden the idea is by the most positive
spin we can put on DeSantis only talking
about mostly talking about Joe Biden
right now is that people who see him
will see him as the nominee and will
Envision and imagine what it would be
like for him to run against Joe Biden
rather than seeing him getting chippy
with Donald Trump they see him as the
Challenger to Biden and they might say
oh I can see this working better than
what it was like in 2020 when Trump ran
against Joe Biden so the idea is to
plant the vision in the minds of Voters
of hey this guy could be the nominee
this is what it would be like however
however I don't see how just saying
stuff like I will destroy leftism and
Biden is bad is going to get Trump
supporters to say maybe I will go for
DeSantis and I also don't know how it's
going to bring in new voters into the
Republican primary so as a strategy I
don't really get it second it's really
important to remember with all of this
anti-woke stuff most people are on the
woke side not the anti-woke side the
leftism that DeSantis says he will
destroy
is increasingly what Americans believe
we have numerous polls at this point
these are not outlier polls in any way
which not by a huge margin but like 55
to 45 57 to 43 60 to 40. when you ask
Americans their views on what we might
consider issues of wokeness right views
on inclusivity views on trans people
views on drag shows and book Banning and
race relations and these sorts of things
people the country is coming out
on the side of wokeness and so DeSantis
maybe this would work in Florida I mean
it in a sense it did because he won by
19 I believe it was in his re-election
campaign to Governor the math isn't
there
for it working nationally he says he's
going to destroy the movement that is
the foremost movement defending human
rights right now the Republican party is
not the party of Defending human rights
economic Justice LGBT rights uh
defending the climate teaching kids
critical thinking I could go on and on
that's the movement DeSantis says he
wants to destroy so forget about I don't
know that this will win in the primary I
don't think that this will win him a
general election either and then we get
to the third aspect of this and this is
really the saddest one and one that is
more in line with a lot of the things
we've talked about on this program this
is a totally anti-intellectual argument
and I know that the the Republican party
has become the anti and
pseudo-intellectual party it's been this
way for decades instead of engaging with
specific ideas and trying to refute the
evidence put forth by the left the left
of which I consider myself apart
DeSantis is either interested or you
might even say obsessed with just
dismissing the entire left outright and
the dismissive attitude is also towards
intellectual discourse it's towards
higher education it's work towards
learning and thinking and epistemology
and media literacy and critical thinking
and all of those things and we can say
oh it's because he's pandering to dumb
Republicans okay yeah there are
Republicans that are dumb but the danger
in it is that it undermines the
Democratic process because it gets
people thinking about elections or
better said not really thinking about
them in ways that allow the Democratic
process to be corroded which we saw on
January 6th and which we've seen other
attempts made trying to overturn the
election Etc and then lastly
he's going to need I mean listen I don't
know that I would say DeSantis needs
Progressive support to win but he
certainly needs moderate support
probably Sun some Center left people who
might say I don't really like Biden and
while DeSantis is to my right I'm going
to vote for him because he's extending
an olive branch and reaching out to me
when you say I will destroy leftism you
blatantly ignore and debase your
Progressive constituents and DeSantis in
that way is going to shut himself off
from even maybe getting a little bit of
that voter base he's limiting his voter
base to the most extreme elements of the
Republican party and I guess like
right-leaning Independence maybe but the
open-minded Independence to the extent
that they exist left-leaning
Independence Centrist Democrats some of
whom DeSantis might be able to pick up
if he had a more conciliatory tone he's
going to lose all of them without with I
will destroy leftism so right now
desantis's approach doesn't seem like a
viable approach to defeating Donald
Trump to even secure this nomination and
it certainly doesn't seem like a viable
approach to defeating Joe Biden in the
next couple days and maybe even by
tomorrow in time for tomorrow's show we
will have post announcement polling in a
hypothetical matchup against Biden I'm
curious to see what that will look like
make sure you're following us on Tick
Tock where we are approaching
this is an unbelievable number we are
approaching half a million Tick Tock
followers we have not grown this quickly
on any platform ever
make sure you're following us on Tick
Tock and make sure you're subscribed on
the YouTube channel as well
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
Donald Trump announced yesterday in a
sick and disgusting video that on day
one of his next presidency if he is to
get one he will violate the constitution
of the United States Trump loves the
Constitution just like he loves American
flags and Law and Order and all of these
different things Trump loves the
Constitution and many of his followers
see it almost like a sacred religious
document and yet Trump says on day one
of his presidency if he is inaugurated
in January of 2025 he will sign an
executive order ending Birthright
citizenship as guaranteed by the 14th
Amendment to the Constitution of the
United States here is Donald Trump
looking admittedly a little confused not
clear he knows where he is or what he's
saying uh take a listen to what he says
plan to secure the border on day one
of my new chairman office I will sign an
executive order making clear to federal
agencies that under the correct
interpretation of the law
going forward the future children of
illegal aliens will not receive
automatic U.S citizenship yeah now he
says there according to some
interpretations of the law if you can
find me serious legal experts who
believe that Birthright citizenship
could be denied as written in the 14th
Amendment please send me that because
all of the research I did this morning
matches up with my uh prior discussions
with legal experts on the matter which
is it is very clearly part of the 14th
Amendment now I want to focus in on one
particular aspect of this the right
Wingers cheerleading this idea and
Birthright citizenship and anchor babies
as they love to call them those right
Wingers should be very careful about the
unintended consequences that Trump
trying to do this could have first of
all
it does appear it would violate the
constitution and the Supreme Court
precedent which established that there
is a fundamental right to citizenship if
born in the United States
right-wingers claim to worship that
document as a religious text and indeed
it appears as though this is a
fundamental right
if they were to attempt this it would be
potentially years and years and years of
legal
conundra we might call it and in the
immediate it would much more quickly
increase the undocumented population in
the United States which they claim to
want to reduce this is a really
important thing if Trump ends Birthright
citizenship going forward then you are
going to have a situation where babies
will be born here
will immediately be undocumented
presumably subject to deportation and it
will so instantly clog up and gum up
immigration processes that because you
will all of a sudden see authorities
tied up with looking at deporting
newborn babies you actually might you
know they say that we really care about
criminal aliens the people committing
crimes Etc to the extent that they exist
and they do to a degree but just not to
the the degree that Donald Trump says
you are going to get in the way
of actually locating and deporting those
individuals who are only not only
undocumented but have committed uh
crimes because you are going to be
focusing on trying to deport newborn
babies they are going to make the
problem they want to fix worse secondly
it will impact the American economy it
will reduce the labor force it will
reduce the tax base it will reduce
consumer Demand by just getting rid of
people and their families even if
they're babies and they're not spending
their own money you are going to push
them as well as potentially parents out
of the United States you will reduce the
tax base reduce the labor force and
reduce consumer demand that's not good
for the economy years of legal
challenges will also come with them will
bring with them huge financial costs
these claim to be fiscal conservatives
but of course it will be extraordinarily
expensive and it will destroy
International image of the United States
now that's not anything new you might
remember that Gallup Global surveys
about global opinion about the the
United States
bottomed out when Trump was president
has fortunately started to recover since
Joe Biden became president but again the
United States for all of our faults the
United States has been seen
generally not every part of the United
States but generally the United States
has been seen as a nation that Embraces
immigrants offers opportunity to those
born within its borders and if you end
Birthright citizenship particularly in
this vindictive way you're going to
tarnish that image and then that will
make it more difficult to continue uh
having the exact same relationships
diplomatically with our long-term allies
there will be other countries affected
by the policy change on and on and on
and there are question marks as to what
such a decision by Trump would do to
National Security efforts and what I
mean by that is that Birthright
citizenship has implications for
National Security because it says okay
if you're born here
you have a vested interest in the
country you get citizenship that creates
a tie if you end Birthright citizenship
for people born here you can create all
sorts of different security issues legal
gray areas raise questions about rights
and obligations of individuals within
the country it's extraordinarily
problematic in a number of different
ways now do we believe Trump will
actually do this on day one of his
presidency I don't know I mean I I
genuinely don't know Trump says a lot of
things he told us in August of 2020 that
we were two weeks away from receiving
his new health care plan
I'm still waiting for it I'm really
curious what would be in there maybe he
meant August of 2024 I don't know at
this point in time but Will trump
actually do it unclear would this be a
good idea no would it even be
constitutional probably not Donald Trump
has now turned on his darling former
press secretary Kaylee mcinanny in a
Bonkers truth social rant truth Central
Donald Trump trothing to Central quote
Kaylee milk toast macananny now oh God
I'm gonna get back to this he writes
milk toast like you would make a piece
of toast with milk like Japanese milk
bread okay
um this is not the word this is not the
spelling of milk toast but we'll get
back to that Kaylee milk toast macananny
just gave out the wrong poll numbers on
Fox news I am up 30 I am 34 points up on
Des sanctimonious not 25 up while 25 is
great it's not 34. she knew the number
was corrected upwards by the group that
did the poll
the rhinos and globalists can have her
Fox News should only use real stars so
let's look at this in pieces first of
all the word is milk toast
m-i-l-q-u-e it has a couple of
definitions timid Meek or unassertive
lacking in character or vigor
um milk toast like we would talk about
bread is something different altogether
although it is delicious I will admit
that Japanese milk bread if you toasted
it is really something else so let's
talk about the strategy the strategy to
the extent that there is one is Trump
turning on everyone
for any reason at all if they don't do
the metaphorical bow down and pray at
the altar of trump
in this particular case Kaylee mcinanny
just gave polling numbers that Trump
feels are different or inaccurate or
were revised in some way it doesn't seem
like this is a good strategy for two
different reasons number one if you are
going to immediately viciously turn on
anyone not even for criticizing you but
just for reporting polling data that may
be disfavorable in some way to you or
not as favorable as you want it to be uh
you are going to very quickly run out of
allies because you're going to end up
turning on a lot of different people and
secondly it runs the risk of alienating
other former staffers even if Trump if
you're a trump former Trump staffer and
I don't know maybe you'd be involved in
his 2024 campaign maybe you wouldn't if
you see Trump turning on other former
staffers for essentially nothing
are you going to be ready and willing to
defend Trump to work for Trump to help
Trump in any way it seems like the
answer is no now this is just this is a
very funny thing
um Kaylee mcinanny was hosting something
on Fox news I guess maybe she has a show
now on Fox News I don't even remember
and Congressman chip Roy uses the word
milk toast as a reference to the fact
that Trump called her milk toast this
this is actually a little bit funny
starting with you Congressman chip Roy
realistic alternative to this because I
understand we wouldn't formally default
we can pay the interest on our debt but
our debt could be downgraded and that
could be catastrophic so what is the
realistic alternative to this deal
well thanks Kaylee uh first of all you
know the everything that we're seeing
out of the bill that was put forward
this this deal this hatch this weekend
is pretty milk toast if uh if that word
might mean something to you but frankly
uh the real problem we've all right so
very very clever there chip Roy
um the more Trump turns on former
staffers the more likely it is that is
2024 campaign will be made up of even
more incompetent staffers which actually
sounds very fun to me even if it's not
going to be a particularly good strategy
for winning in 2024. so Kaylee mcinany
the latest Trump staffer former staffer
to see Trump turn on them and remember
Trump's idea of loyalty is
you never criticized Trump okay
you never questioned Trump's judgment
all right you always praise Trump
anytime his name comes up it's getting a
little difficult you don't even report
polling data that Trump doesn't like
that's a tough standard for loyalty that
is a genuinely tough standard for
loyalty it's going to be tough to keep
that one up particularly if desantis's
rise in the polls over the last 10 days
is not a blip and it is a new change of
Direction but we will follow it after
the break Joe Biden's sexual assault
accuser Tara Reid has defected to Russia
do you know anything about Russia they
asked me and I said I don't know
anything about it well that's where uh
Joe Biden's sexual assault accuser has
uh defected to we're going to talk a lot
more about believe all women in the
context of this defection stay tuned
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright so
Tara Reid who accused Joe Biden of
sexual assault claiming the incident
took place in 1993 tried to derail his
2020 presidential campaign
she has defected to Russia
what the hell is going on here the
guardian reporting former Senate staffer
who made claim in 2020 appears on
Russian media alongside convicted
Russian agent in the United States Maria
boutina I'm still kind of in a daze but
I feel very good Reid told Sputnik the
Russian press outlet that supports Putin
while sitting with Maria boutina a
convicted Russian agent jailed in the
U.S but now A Member of Parliament in
Russia I feel very surrounded by
protection and safety now 59 Reed was a
staffer for Biden when he was a senator
from Delaware in 2020 she said that back
in 93 in a senate hallway he pushed her
against the wall and assaulted her Biden
denied it at her press appearance Reed
was described as a writer and publicist
former aide to Joe Biden boutina sitting
next to boutina Reid said I just really
so appreciate Maria and everyone who's
been giving me protection at a time when
it's been very difficult to know if I'm
safe or not I just didn't want to walk
home and walk into a cage or be killed
which is basically my two choices so she
has indeed defected to Russia she says
it was difficult she's not impulsive she
takes her time
and what she could see was that uh I
guess with the 24 election gearing up
she's better off in Russia being safe
she wants to live in both places but she
may only live in Russia and that's okay
so I want to talk about this for a very
specific reason so I'm on the right back
when Tara Reid made these allegations
against Joe Biden some on the right
called the left out as Hypocrites and
what those on the right said to those on
the left was listen on the one hand you
leftists say we should believe all women
and then Tara Reid comes forward forward
and says Biden assaulted me and you
don't believe Tara Reid and so it's
important to understand that believe all
women in principle
doesn't mean
you blindly indefinitely believe every
single allegation and this has always
been the case this was what I said when
Justice Kavanaugh was accused this was
what I've always said the right wing
wants to use Tara Reid's allegations to
say that Democrats and leftists actually
have a double standard on me too and
that it's actually just a political tool
me too believe all women if the accused
is a republican but if it's Joe Biden
suddenly you don't believe all women and
this couldn't be further from reality
believe all women
has always meant
if an alleged victim comes forward you
take that seriously you understand that
any time a victim comes forward to say I
was victimized there is risk to them and
that they could be uh pushed one way or
the other stigmatize all these different
things and regardless of political
affiliation you investigate
that doesn't mean that every allegation
is automatically true or that the
allegations are free from scrutiny it
means every accuser should be heard and
respected and held accountable for the
truth and consistency of their claims
Tara Reid's claims were not consistent
and they did not appear to be true after
significant investigation believe all
women isn't a slogan that says You must
have unending Blind Faith period it is a
call to deal with systemic sexism and
misogyny the sort of stigma and
circumstances that historically have
silenced and dismissed women who have
experienced sexual violence it means we
want Justice we want accountability for
the perpetrators of such crimes
including those who have often escaped
punishment because they were in
positions of power or privilege we
recognize women are more likely to be
victims than they are Liars when it
comes to sexual assault
false claims of sexual assault and rape
are quite rare and when they happen they
should be dealt with seriously none of
this is new go back two years go back
five years go back 10 years this is what
I have been saying and when you looked
at the Tara read situation she made an
allegation and as far as I recall
certainly we took it very seriously okay
Joe Biden denied it fine many times
perpetrators deny things Joe Biden also
has a long record of supporting women's
rights and combating sexual violence in
contrast to Trump with his dozens of
accusations against him who doesn't have
that record Joe Biden said I will
cooperate with any investigation I will
release all relevant records related to
Tara Reid Donald Trump did not do that
and the contrast couldn't be more
glaring so what we need to understand is
that these right Wingers are desperate
to call the Tara Reid story
a story of hypocrisy because on some
level they must realize that when we say
believe all women we're not saying
unquestionably except all allegations
with no scrutiny it's a reminder that we
take allegations seriously we support
the survivors we conduct thorough
investigations we ascertain the truth
and I can't think of any case that
better encapsulates that than the Tara
Reid situation and now that she has been
praising Putin and has defected to
Russia in my mind it only raises even
more doubts about her motivations and
her agenda and her allegiances so there
it is sort of like the cherry on top
Tara Reid has now defected to Russia
this is so funny how the tables have
turned remember when Chick-fil-A the uh
chicken fast food restaurant was the
darling of the right wing because it
took a an anti-gay stance and donations
to uh anti-lgbt organizations and
conservatives were flocking to the
drive-throughs and standing in line
outside Chick-fil-A because Chick-fil-A
supports traditional marriage and
so-called Christian values and the left
was boycotting Chick-fil-A because of
bigotry and discrimination times have
changed and I guess Chick-fil-A has also
changed Chick-fil-A has now come under
Fire from its former right-wing fans
because Chick-fil-A now has a statement
on its website about Dei as they like to
call it Dei stands for diversity
equity and inclusion and right Wingers
are now saying Chick-fil-A has succumbed
to the woke agenda there's a piece in
Newsweek Chick-fil-A faces a
conservative revolt
for its Dei initiative
um the company website now said this is
like speaking of milk toast this is milk
toast one of our core values at
Chick-fil-A is we're better together
when we combine our unique backgrounds
and experiences with a culture of
belonging we can discover new ways to
strengthen the quality of care we
deliver to customers to the communities
we serve into the world we understand
that getting better at together means we
learn better care better grow better and
serve better
um okay
so listen there's a couple different
things here the irony is as delicious as
a spicy chicken sandwich with extra
pickles and grilled jalapenos
the same people who accused liberals of
being intolerant cancel culture
supporting lunatics
are now themselves calling for a boycott
of Chick-fil-A
because Chick-fil-A is now being
inclusive and respectful the same people
who previously defended Chick-fil-A's
right to express its religious beliefs
which happen to be Christian those
people are now outraged that Chick-fil-A
is trying to live up to its mission of
glorifying God by being a good Steward
by having this Dei inclusivity statement
and it seems to me that some of these
conservatives must think that to be
faithful to God you shouldn't be
inclusive and want equity and want
diversity seems to me that that is quite
Godly isn't it they think oh Chick-fil-A
wants to have a positive influence I
guess that means we need to boycott them
now Chick-fil-A is not perfect I have
not done a u-turn on Chick-fil-A I've
still never been to a Chick-fil-A
Chick-fil-A is a big corporation that is
calculating what is best for them right
now they have done some to try to repair
the damage they did in terms of their
relationship with the LGBT community
based on what happened a couple of years
ago they have a Dei statement let's see
if they prove that it's not just lip
service let's see if they actually are
committed to some kind of change as a
result of this but it is also not the
enemy of the right wing this is a
business adapting to Changing Times
trying to meet the needs and
expectations of its customers its
employees and its would-be customers I
was think
of trying Chick-fil-A this weekend with
all of this hubbub I've never been I'm
going to be out on Long Island for a
conference this weekend and I thought
there's a bunch of Chick-fil-As there
but then I looked at the menu
it's pretty nuts like I don't want to
you know I I'm all for I'll try all
sorts of different things but I looked
at the the menu
um and you know the rib meat with water
injected into it and formed into a Patty
and then breaded and deep fried like I I
just don't know that I want that you
know so it's it's pretty Bonker stuff
but you know maybe I'll show up and get
like a grilled chicken and report back
how it is in the meantime Marjorie
Taylor green and her boyfriend on their
latest podcast commented about
Chick-fil-A and they wrongly claimed
that the left was boycotting Chick-fil-A
because Chick-fil-A would close on
Sunday which is of course very much not
true so I don't see the left
power
dawg in the marketplace I think that's a
great analogy uh you brought up
Chick-fil-A a lot of us have forgotten
about Chick-fil-A being being boycotted
um and targeted so heavily like they did
on the left uh people were mad at them
simply because they they closed their
doors on Sundays uh because the owners
of Chick-fil-A are Christians and they
believe in taking a day of rest uh like
the Bible talks about like God says you
should rest one day a week and that's
what the owners of Chick-fil-A decided
that's the way they're going to run
their company and they don't apologize
for it and the left targeted them
because they're Christians and yeah and
their stance on marriage ah there
so even Marjorie Taylor Green's
boyfriend having to say Well it did have
some their stance on marriage it did
also actually have to do with their
support of anti-lgbt causes it wasn't
just being closed on Sunday many
businesses are closed on Sunday uh many
Jewish delis are closed during Shabbat
that's being closed on certain days for
religious observance is very different
than than donating to anti-gay causes so
maybe I'll go to Chick-fil-A this
weekend I guess I'll go grilled rather
than fried that that um the rib meat
with the water injected into it I'm just
not big on that I have to admit it's
just it doesn't sound great to me but I
will report back if I end up at a
Chick-fil-A we have a voicemail number
that number is 219 to David P here is a
caller
so deranged and incoherent I don't know
if they're under the influence of drugs
or alcohol in this phone call
um it is it is Troy York under a fake
name and he seems Furious that I think
well let me just play it it's about
I don't even know what he thinks it's
something related to what I said about
tipping hey David Pacman David brookson
yeah hey you're a hypocrite
um Pac-Man you made a video about not
wanting a tip when you go out to a
restaurant and well remember it's not
about not wanting to tip I tip well
Everywhere I Go
it's about I don't like tipping culture
and I would like to restructure it so
that tips aren't expected and people are
paid a living wage apparently it sounds
like you go out to eat a lot like that
the best fine dining restaurants all
right well you know if I want to go out
to eat I'll go out to eat Troy it has no
it's not in your business oh no are you
at a truck fun kid or a hedge fun kid I
am neither I I am a self-made man and uh
but the question is uh Mr packing um
well the point I want to bring off is
you're always doing anti-trump
um videos
and then you do a video on the service
industry and the restaurants
and how workers should not rely on tips
they should have wages
yeah living wages I I believe you say
and
um
well that's what Trump was trying to do
he was trying to bring back good
jobs that the Democrats sent overseas to
China right yeah so listen Trump didn't
have any idea how to do that many of
those jobs simply no longer exist and it
has nothing to do with tipping culture
I'm afraid to break it to you and one
time you didn't have so many of these
restaurants in this country there are
way too many restaurants and most of
them are foreign owned globalists
who who played money Grand games they
shuffled money laundering and
most of these restaurants should not
exist but only exist because of
globalization all right this is very
crazy I guess Troy what I guess he only
has so-called American food I don't know
it's a very very strange message but
listen I uh for for as long as
restaurant workers
depend on tips I'm going to tip my point
is I would like a different structure
where we have prices the prices include
all fees and then the employees are paid
a living wage that's what I would like
to see we're going to talk about deep
fake technology on the bonus show today
and the role that it might play in the
2024 election we are also going to talk
about Air New Zealand the airline
starting to weigh passengers before they
board international flights and the
impact that this is having and North
Korea's attempt to launch its first spy
satellite
has ended in failure
and it is pretty humiliating all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad I can't
say it much better than that thank you
Alex so I will leave it with you as
please sign up at joinpakman.com get
access to the bonus show otherwise we'll
be back tomorrow with a new show see you
then
thank you
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors it's springtime
you're outside more it is time for
sunscreen but stay away from the
chemical sunscreens with ingredients
that can irritate skin cause hormonal
disruption or Worse instead use mineral
sunscreen by Ginger armor which is just
as effective you'll get 15 off with code
Pacman at gingerarmor.com the link is
down below